actually I can just talk because I know
what you're going to ask you ready
guys yes Julian was really good today uh
he uh he had a really really big impact
um he brought us the energy that we need
us that he okay scoring he still need to
learn when you score a little bit the
defense going to be someone else is
going to be open but that's fine uh yes
we we feel really confident with Colin
playing with us on the on the on the
floor uh but I think he needs to be a
little bit more aggressive just because
uh for confidence for him for himself uh
uh he he's kind of looking to play for
others which is a good thing uh but U I
think it's going to help us too if he's
a little bit more aggressive uh uh in
the future whatever um yes third quarter
was really amazing for us uh it's uh
especially after after after the first
half we didn't have a really
really the energy the ball didn't move
we finished with we we finished the game
with 37 assists which is which is really
good really really good uh uh and only
nine turnovers I think in the first half
we didn't uh create for we didn't move
create for others we kind of play I
don't want to say selfish basketball but
it was uh we didn't run at all of course
they made they made a lot of shots they
made a lot of Threes uh I mean the
people that we know that they're
shooting well but we
didn't kind of the the all focus and and
all uh we didn't have a focus in the
first half but the second half was I
think we beat them like 7 75 to
40 75 to 45 so I mean that was uh that
was I think uh that's where we won the
game of course and yes I passed Jason
kid on uh uh what's the name uh third
fourth fourth uh triple double andas the
guy is still playing I think he's gonna
have a couple more uh it's it's some of
course it's some Legacy that I'm trying
to that um is going to be there when I'm
probably stop playing basketball is that
the end of your
podcast no I think that's that's it we
say good night I mean if you guys have
something what's the effect that you
know you guys don't have long time
what's the effect on you guys you
compensate for that I mean the guys